I heard you like top ten fight videos
well don't worry I got you covered okay
tens not a good number to stop out when
we talk about the best anime fights of
the decade so here's an advanced
Christmas present for you shortly after
the first video I decided to make a list
of ten more anime fights to look out for
when reliving the best of anime this
past decade
yes our decade in rewind series
continues with a second set of anime
fights let's get the ball rolling in the
only fashion an amazing anime like FMA
Brotherhood deserves to close we have
the final battle against father after
absorbing souls and basically becoming
God father finds himself face to face
with everyone the military the rebels
Mustang was left of him anyway and the
Elric's after everyone's bombardment and
some timely assistance from greed
father's finally worn out and taken down
in a sweet beat down by edy
the battle is great for me because in
addition to the spectacle of EDS
no-holds-barred beatdown it showed two
fundamental parts of the series themes
one which is the strength of unity
despite being strong fighters in their
own right none of them could stand a
chance of taking down a being that
transcends all limits nevertheless it's
everyone working together that shows how
much people can accomplish if they work
together it's also good to note the
thematic irony that despite being so
powerful father did himself in the
opened himself up to defeat by focusing
on preserving and increasing power just
like the Elric's father fell due to
pride and his attempt at going against
taboo
[Music]
Helsing's full of edgy and badass
overpowered characters and the
long-awaited fight between Alucard and
anderson is its version of the
unstoppable force versus the immovable
object
after a long wait anderson decides it's
time to finally finish the vampire in
london Alucard quickly takes command of
the fight overwhelming his rival with
familiars before the latter gets saved
and unveils his secret weapon helen is
nail and a since transformation into a
monster puts him on par with the vampire
serices intervention then provides alec
on a second wind allowing him to finally
finish off his transformed rival the
fight delivered for what is the final
battle between the two rivals the whole
great respect from one another in the
end
Alucard proves to be too much for
Anderson to handle I mean he has a
commanding lead and would have
eventually won before the running
started happening one after another
[Music]
now for the first fight on the list that
doesn't involve the main protagonist of
the series a highlight of a foes third
season is the battle between Nakamura
and David Eagle pitting the wild and
aggressive style of taka Mora against
the calm and textbook moves of the
American gold medalist makes her a
suspenseful and intriguing match while
most boxers have gimmicky fighting
styles David Eagle has a simple arsenal
he doesn't have much in the way of
finishing moves but it's foolish to
underestimate him while the lack of all
those flashy moves may mean that he has
no particular strengths it also means
that you really just have to be better
than Eagle in order to beat him with his
fighting strategy being so grounded
there's really no major weakness to
exploit either Nakamura sure and learned
that the hard way
after a grueling match that featured his
eye problems he beat the American in the
boxing ring but sure had to go through
hell to win what makes this fight so
impactful is the ending seeing him punch
non-stop for 10 seconds through sheer
willpower is just so emotional and epic
at the same time
[Music]
[Music]
this is a cool case
Psychopaths is 16th episode gave us a
gift to remember a battle between the
two most charismatic characters I
remember the fight having tons of hype
the first time around because we've yet
to know the full extent of makishima's
fighting abilities and whether he could
beat kogami
what makes this fight special is how
realistic it is good old hand-to-hand
combats great and another thing to note
is how makishima and kogami ford
represented their personalities in
essence the fights a battle between a
graceful style and a rough aggressive
style although I won't blame you if you
didn't notice it the first time around
because you were so absorbed with the
spectacle the choreography is just
amazing and if you want to find a fight
that can convince you to give
psycho-pass a shot perhaps this is the
one
[Music]
next we take a look at ODOT vs. G day
this arcs one of the reasons why I love
bungo stray dogs so much and what a way
to finish it with the awesome short but
sweet battle what better way to fight a
villain than with powers that are
similar now let me up the ante and say
that both fighters have Future Sight as
their powers a fast and furious gunfight
follows gifted by the ability to pierce
seconds into the future and predict each
other's movements the two fighters
exchange shots
seemingly being unable to hit each other
due to the future site where people
jokingly compare this short fight as a
battle between two Sharingan users or
two King Crimson's I guess it's not too
far off the mark if you're up for a
fight with blazingly quick action and a
sequence of events then this fight is
for you in a battle between two uses of
precognition the first hit usually
decides the victor who would come out on
top
among the numerous fights in mob sico
I'd say that mob versus Montgomery
should be a contender for the best ones
in the decade simply put the battle
between the two takes place in
figuratively multiple dimensions it's
more of a psychological battle taking
place initially inside Minori Mob
initially proves to be the superior
fighter overwhelming Mogami before
falling into the latter's trap and being
forced into enduring mental torment it
takes dimples intervention to snap mob
out of it and defeat Mogami notably the
fights marked by the release of mobs
question mark percentage mode one of his
most amazing forms and power-ups
despite being weaker physically Mogami
showed what he's really capable of in
this battle and along with mob psychos
renowned animation showed us a beautiful
example of a mental battle in a shounen
series done right
your greatest enemy is yourself right I
don't know but you should properly ask
Emmie Oshiro about that after all his
greatest challenge in unlimited blade
works in my opinion isn't even the king
of heroes it's his future self fed up
with the world he fought to protect and
turning into a cynic
the battle between shiro and answer is
not the most spectacular in unlimited
blade works but it's arguably the most
meaningful and climactic one especially
for our protagonist shiro literally
stands no chance against Archer in
straight-up combat however this battle
isn't about strength there's really only
one win Khan for either of them breaking
down the other's ideals and making them
accept their choices in life are wrong
in this battle of willpower
it's Shiro who comes out on top even
though Archer has the fight won by all
means he hesitates after being faced
with the harsh reality of seeing his
past ideal self
[Music]
episode 5 of part 2 of attack on titans
third season features a tripleheader of
the most awaited fights in the series
history after their initial
introductions as beings of destruction
in the reveal of their identities it's
finally time to take down the Beast the
armored and colossal Titans recovered
Lee by taking on the beast Titan and
Aaron and his squad sacrifice in another
video before so this time I'm focusing
on the remaining fights with those
characters out of the way it's Aaron and
arming left in charge to take care of
the colossal Titan since the start of
the series I knew this baton was gonna
happen but what surprised me was that it
was Arman's brilliant plan that decides
the battle but not without steep cost
meanwhile the rest of the group go up
against the armored Titan whom they
decide to defeat outright despite their
struggles they finally get breathing
room as hanji opens up the door to their
counter-attack with thunder spears
badass Mikasa finishes off the armored
Titan ending the last among the three
Titans reign of terror for good the
fights are amazing and give everyone
their shine finally after three long
seasons humanity finally vanquishes the
most prominent monsters among the Titans
where all the sacrifice is worth it
that's debatable but at least we've got
a series of battles worthy of even being
grouped together as the series grand
finale out of it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
no doubt the final stretch of the great
ninja war gave us many notable and hype
moments while we can talk about motherís
domination Minato saving the day
team sevens last battle on Naruto and
Sasuke fated showdown
I'd like to feature another battle that
deserves praise and a mention ever since
the flash back to Kakashi's past in the
introduction of Obito I had an inkling
that the Uchiha is probably still alive
somewhere when he's relieved to be Tobi
it's only natural that he and his former
childhood friend gravitate towards each
other and settle things once and for all
this fight easily has the best
hand-to-hand combat action we've seen in
Naruto up to this point the fight itself
isn't only backed by high brought about
by history but by how well their powers
synergize with one another their battle
inside Kamui's dimension is all sorts of
intense and pits the best of the best in
terms of their similar eye powers the
fight might have been overshadowed by
Obito's quick transformation but don't
let that distract you from the fact that
before he becomes the master of the ten
tails Morita had one hell of a fight
against his former friend
[Music]
and that just about wraps it up I wonder
which fight ended up being your favorite
I'd love to know about your personal top
ten lists as well that's got to do it
for now would you like to see the volume
three for this one if this video gets
10k likes then I'll definitely consider
it so don't forget to subscribe and hit
the notification bell so you don't miss
a thing
I'll be seeing you in the next video
[Music]